hey hey how you doing yeah and not too
bad can i get the blt please
you got it awesome now that is gonna be
five
dollars five dollars all right
i could throw in chips
and we'll call it
seven dollars uh that sounds great but i
just want the sandwich for five if
that's okay
[Music]
now before you do
before you walk away
we also have something called a meal
deal
i throw in chips and a drink
for eight dollars i brought my own drink
i actually don't need one smart so can i
just have the sandwich yes five great
thank you one more thing
i'm not supposed to tell you about this
it's called our meal pass meal pass
that's right for six dollars i give you
a cookie in five minutes you give me a
cookie in five minutes that's right how
many different ways do you have to
package the sandwich
you want to hear about our bread buster
edition don't you look over here
[Music]
the point season 3 episode 6 a friendly
reminder that dlc still sucks
[Music]
hey guess what evolve came out that game
you've heard a bunch about from those
people that made that popular zombie
series where everyone's giving each
other pills four hunters tracking down
one big old monster and probably the
most brilliantly designed logo in the
history of video games a fun game with
dozens of map mode and monster
combinations so what's all the fuss
about well with the game that's been
designed with so much variety i guess
the marketing team over at 2k the game's
publisher decided they wanted to get in
on the act announcing 6 billion ways to
buy the game including dlc bundles
expansion packs pre-order bonuses and
special editions so why is this pissed
off a bunch of people well it seems in
2015 we still can't stomach dlc
gaming has always been an expensive
pastime who's this fresh face
[__] oh yeah that's me almost
five years ago in fact in the summer of
2010 complaining about dlc no less back
then it was all horse armor and avatar
top hats stuff you didn't really need
elements that didn't impact on gameplay
much but even then the idea of paying
for some supplemental [__] was
unpalatable why let's rewind back a few
more years to 1999. back then three
shooters ruled the roost quake 3 unreal
tournament and half-life the first two
online shooters had shed loads of maps
modes and character models but they also
came packed with mod tools allowing
talented players to create their own
maps their own modes and their own
models content that was shared freely
through download sites magazine cover
disks and across lan party networks
valve went a step further with half-life
releasing free multiplayer shooter team
fortress classic in an attempt to
wrestle multiplayer attention away from
the other two that was the lay of the
land back then small content was free
but most big gameplay impacting updates
came in the form of boxed expansion
packs they cost about half the price of
the full game were usually released at
least a year afterwards and generally
didn't impact on the core game itself
too much
but then the internet got fast
ruined everything
so what made the sea change well for one
broadband worldwide distribution is an
expensive risky world so developers
always had to err on the side of caution
when they made boxed expansion packs as
they usually required the base game and
so had a smaller install base right at
the gate most were content rich and at a
competitive retail price but as
high-speed broadband became the norm
they were no longer restricted by this
market reality digital goods cost little
to ship excess stock doesn't take up
space in warehouses now they could just
throw any old [__] out in an online
store and if it didn't sell
it didn't really matter so they did and
apparently we loved buying horse armor
and frigging top hats for our avatars so
they started charging us above the norm
for content that we actually wanted in
this old video from before my time at
gamespot i'm complaining about the
modern warfare 2 stimulus package three
new multiplayer maps plus two lifted
wholesale from call of duty 4 for the
low low price of about 12
i implored people to vote with their
pockets and not bite on this obvious bad
deal but we didn't we ate that [__] up
and look where we are now it seems every
game has a dlc strategy and though we'd
like to believe that stuff isn't
actually being torn out of the main game
i think most of us still think we're
often getting ripped off as if our
chosen hobby wasn't expensive enough as
it is consoles cost 400 a pop pc is
about 3 times as much it's still about
60 for a boxed game hd televisions hdmi
cables extra controllers let's say
another 50 a month for a decent internet
connection five dollars a month for
every console you want to play online we
already spend a shed load of cash to
enjoy playing games our past time of
choice doesn't involve a 10 cinema
ticket a spotify subscription or a
library card it involves making informed
decisions about the cash we spend on
games i'll watch a [__] film for 90
minutes and not really think anything of
it but games require a time and cash
investment that forces us to be engaged
in their value prospect so the one thing
you don't want to feel when you're
partying with sixty dollars of your hard
earned cash is that you're getting some
truncated version of the full game and
guess what when you launch a game with
that much optional content that's how
people are going to feel from what i've
played evolve has enough content for the
60 asking price but 2k's marketing team
have rubbed up against some sensitive
nerves games are expensive enough as
they are so we have to be engaged
consumers when we part with our cash but
when you use car salesman techniques to
upsell people to a seemingly good deal
on a game they've not had time to play
at you disrespect the very people you
should be thanking i'm still not okay
with loads of dlc if i'm being
completely honest i like the developers
can add to their games post release and
i like that i have the option to pick
that stuff up if i want to but please
don't shove it in my face right at the
gate allowing me to enjoy the game that
you made and then once i've had my fill
i can decide if i want to spend more
money on it
[Music]
that right there
that was quake 3 team arena
you